We just saw how to fetch a
single document using an HTTP
request.
These documents can be
any kind of data, really.
But on the web,
everything usually
starts with an index document.
The index document
is what the server
will send back to you
if no explicit file is
to find in the request.
By typing at URL in the
address bar of the browser,
the user is
instructing the browser
to open a new connection
to the server identified
by the hostname in the URL and
getting the document specified
in the path of the URL.
In this case, the server will
respond with the index.html,
and the browser can
start parsing it.
This is a really
interesting step,
and the browser does
a number of things
to handle the received data.
Check out the link
in the instructor
notes for an explanation
on how this works.
After the browser has
parsed the response,
things start to
get a little wild.
As the browser is
reading the index.html,
it will probably find references
to other documents needed
to properly display the website.
These can be images, style
sheets, JavaScript files,
videos, you name it.
For each of these resources,
another request is sent,
and once a response is
received by the browser,
this entire process of parsing
and potentially sending
new requests is repeated.
That also means that
each of these resources
can, in turn, pull in
additional resources.
Each landing page
will have its own set
of dependencies, like images,
CSS, and JavaScript files.
That means that
visiting a single URL
can send off many more requests
than you might be aware of.